una advertencia de Estados Unidos Irán y
Rusia están intensificando su
cooperación militar según el portavoz
del Consejo de Seguridad Nacional de la
Casa Blanca el gobierno iraní lleva
varios meses aumentando su apoyo a Moscú
especialmente en materia de aviones no
tripulados
se ha convertido en el principal apoyo
militar de Rusia desde agosto irán a
transferido varios centenares de drones
uav a Rusia Rusia ha estado utilizando
estos uav para atacar las
infraestructuras críticas de Ucrania y
como he dicho antes para matar a
ucranianos
inicialmente haber enviado drones a
Rusia pero más tarde admitió que había
entregado algunos antes de la invasión a
Ucrania Estados Unidos cree que Rusia
también está estudiando desarrollar una
producción conjunta de aviones no
tripulados para utilizarlos en Ucrania
según Estados Unidos el régimen iraní
está considerando la venta de cientos de
misiles balísticos este movimiento
muestra las limitadas opciones del
kremlin para reponer su menguante arsen
armas a cambio de su apoyo
Moscú ha estado proporcionando a Teherán
equipos militares como helicópteros y
sistemas de defensa antiaérea la Casa
Blanca también afirma que los pilotos
iraníes están siendo entrenados en
avanzados aviones de guerra rusos
Estados Unidos impondrá sanciones a las
entidades rusas implicadas en
importación de aviones no tripulados
John Kirby también advirtió que la
asociación entre ambos países Sería
perjudicial para Ucrania los vecinos de
Irán y la comunidad internacional